ti cul lierre au pied de l'appeler ses
notes de baies la donne le ton d'une
matinée riche
pas moins de six bus plus de 400 élèves
et près d'une centaine d'accompagnateurs
s'y étaient donné rendez-vous avant de
partir par petits groupes des conseils
pratiques sont obligatoires sont donnés
sur la montagne vous allez devoir faire
très attention parce que aujourd'hui le
tome et théologique n'est pas au beau
fixe
la tenue de sport et l'imperméable ont
donc remplacé l'uniforme avec un slogan
imprimé sur des t-shirts et dans les
têtes
du moins pour les plus motivés on va
monter jusqu'à oman
tu es motivé la venue très émotif on
voit pas les fois qu'on a à faire c'est
plus amusant aussi parce que là
l'ambiance pour des raisons de sécurité
le départ est échelonné par groupes de
niveau moi qui ne fait pas de ce monde
et les jo ça me permet de me surpasser
je dois avouer que c'est très très
difficile mais j'essaie d'aller au plus
loin comme aussi mais j'ai envie
d'abandonner m ça devient difficile mais
bon il faut tenir le coup pour qu'on
puisse avoir une belle dit qu'on vote de
cette motion
c'est la deuxième fois que je monte
jamais arrivé en haut de respect que la
wii ça te plaît de faire ça avec ton
lycée oui oui c'est cool
à côté des sportifs il ya ceux qui
prennent le temps de découvrir la flore
endémique oblique à quelques fonds du
bégonia honorata voilà c'est une plante
qui s'est bien développé l'idée
maîtresse de ce vaste projet est de
fédérer
fédérer toute une communauté scolaire
autour des valeurs de solidarité et
autour d'enseignement interdisciplinaire
c'est à dire le point de vue historique
les différentes éruption on connaît bien
les options de 1912 mais en a eu avant
il y en a eu après études j'ai en
géographie le type péléen qu'un type
kaslik stick en physique
d'étudier la masse énergétique up
développé à intel volcan et puis il y a
le symbole nous ne cessons de dieu nous
élève chercher l'excellence aller
toujours plus on monte à l'est vers le
sommet et donc l'idée de la montagne
c'était c'était ça enfin nous allons
vers le sommet tous n'auront pas réussi
à aller au delà de leurs capacités
mais peu importe l'équipe pédagogique a
permis à quelques 400 lycéens de
s'approprier un site singulier réputé
est visité par des milliers de personnes
chaque année